here again are the latest phone calls
between Vladimir Putin and President
Trump glad I fired go me dude give it a
lovely place but he's golden mm someone
talented no I mean literally golden a
ghost retriever a really really good boy
I'm good to me yeah he already ate a lot
of the files I think is a good fit maybe
you should learn more talk way ahead of
last hello biggest rap oh whoa you seem
surprised to hear from me why we talk
every day yes didn't you meet with
Russian envoy today
yeah great meeting and didn't they give
you a ceremonial envelope to lick they
tried to but I have a germaphobe so I
skipped it why what was that all about
nothing have to go by what the hell had
an apparent loser Fred my computer guys
didn't exactly deliver the way I wanted
them to I'm about to give them a stern
talking-to right now oh really could I
lifted it
of course this le8 testifying on the
Russia involvement in campaign what kind
of country let the woman use a
microphone I know it's that's right
don't worry I'm going to take care of
her really you'll have something
sinister plan yep you won't believe it
Wow
don't know if I'm impressed this will be
your first kill wait kill no I just
gotta fire up a couple of poorly worded
tweets hey don't call me that
no how about I call you poutine no wait
what is cooking it's a Canadian dish
it's basically french fries with cheese
and gravy okay call me that all right
we'll find this hey Vlad I got a
button that every time I press it they
bring me a coke
have you got a better like that no I
have other buttons yeah what is it deal
with depression you'll find out soon
enough
[Applause]
you